when Henry Cavill walks
through the smoke and he says
I I like truth but I'm a big fan
of Justice favorite Justice League
I think he got a different kind makes me laugh
every time I believe in truth I'm also a big fan
of justice but I'm a big fan of Justice I wish
you walked through and said that I mean like oh
[__] this version no no no no no what have we
done that's Walter ramada's like I was right I
was right that's the one right there we're gonna
meet halfway if you're gonna put Superman in here
what's going on there citizens of the reject
Nation we are going to talk a different kind of
talk about the Black Adam post credit scene I am
of course joined by the buffest man in the comic
book World Coy the man genre how are your biceps
they're doing okay you know I uh interviewed The
Rock and I felt like a small child so I've been
going back extra hard and extra heavens and trying
to keep up it's a good good interview you guys
should watch us on the Nerdist Channel he didn't
want to do it for our Channel I was like no no
specifically not the real rejects so uh there's
a short of koi's uh up here where you can get his
opinion on Black Adam bottom line he liked quite
a bit and then you could watch our non-spoiler
review who I did with John a lesson experience oh
yeah it was all right that's just where I landed
I really didn't expect to be as enamored with it
as I was and I'm happy you did and I've been up
editing way too late too often this past week and
a half to argue with you on it so we were gonna
do a heated debate on the internals and Greg was
like I would like to sleep like you know what I'd
rather just just accept your opinions and except
that I enjoyed it but the post-credits scene
though that is something that has been a massive
talk or something that seems like Dwayne Johnson
himself has really been wanting to get the word
out on there it seems like he wanted it to leak
you know and that's what I find so fascinating
about it I want to go over our emotional reactions
to this and then I want to talk about some of the
lead up to it because I feel like it's just been
such a fascinating journey of what's happened
specifically with this post-credits scene so yeah
real quick we got to go over what happens in this
post-credits scene Black Adam he is now officially
back to being ruler of conduct looks badass
um Walter Ramona I don't know it's Amanda Waller
yeah a little tiny producers just like we don't
want him he's not welcome here three Superman
spin-offs here's the Headless Superman again
some sort of Superman spot I'm so abandoned water
shows up in a drone Dwayne Johnson as Black Adam
says there's no one on this planet that can stop
me Amanda Waller replies I can call in a favor
send people who aren't from this planet and then
bring Green Lantern shows of immersion is everyone
not from this planet after the Dwayne Johnson
says send them all so after he destroys the
Drone suddenly the silhouette descends from
the sky now keep in mind like koi when you
get into his thoughts on his experience with it
because koi had not had it leaked for him he saw
it before a lot of other people and I had had it
leaked for me before watching it like it was just
everywhere and there were some journalists who
like decided just screw it I'm gonna lead with
it and then Dwayne Johnson wasn't helping either
like 20 shots it was like he's in it don't worry
he's gonna be in it but even knowing Henry Cavill
was gonna show up with the original Superman John
Williams scores started playing I was like oh
this is still really exciting this is still great
then when he walks through the smoke and
then you see that he's got a different kind
of hair with a cool little Superman curl
and his suit looks just so beautiful and
Sleek walking through and I think he says a line
that feels like a tad bit meta it's been a while
since anyone's made the world this nervous
I haven't put on this cape in a long time
I definitely made a sound I'm embarrassed
retrograde flame remembering when he comes
through and you first see his face because we've
had so many facelifts I think I was like oh like
I made like an excitable like this is insane this
is it was nuts the whole time there was that rumor
going around for months but since it hadn't been
confirmed in any way you could feel the credits
are about to roll and then when it happened I
was back to phase one Marvel I was like can they
do is it I was so emotional I got back to that
like oh my God they're bringing in characters
from multiple franchises it literally felt like
2008 again where I was like they can do that even
though they've been doing it for 14 years since
I didn't think we'd ever see Henry Cavill again
since I had kind of like let the DC Universe Go I
mean I made a whole video here about what I would
do to relaunch the DC Universe and it was largely
wrap up the films you have now keep a DC Black
Label and then recast the core players launching
from Shazam and Black Adam but that meant
recasting Henry Cavill as much as I love him I
just thought that's the way they were gonna go so
to be honest seeing him on screen with that score
in the perfect suit so perfectly shot I felt like
I did when they first said The Avengers Initiative
yeah I fully felt that magic and then that line
I think is so great because Superman made people
nervous so it kind of sounds like they should team
up oh that'd be cool versus them fighting each
other it does raise some questions instead of bvs
it's b-a-n-s yeah full circle well and I love that
like we also imply that she can call Superman like
that's really interesting too that like Amanda
Waller have any it's kind of weird you know what
I mean it's a bit weird because like Amanda Waller
having dirt on Superman is interesting but weird
since she was always like when you prepare for if
there's a Superman out here you know but we won't
show him because we can't show his face yeah this
is kind of weird that's refer to him a lot Manuel
could just call on Superman but I also like the
idea that Superman is already like keeping an
eye on Black Adam so then it's just like okay you
had one chance to do it your way yeah I'm gonna
do it my way but I would love to see any sort
of interaction whether it team up or fight and
to be honest I would personally rather it team up
between the two of them and and he's The Reluctant
foil because I if we have a Black Adam versus
Superman movie it could easily be like Dragon
Ball Z where it's for two hours it'd be great I
would watch it I'd be excited about it and you
could lean into the anti-hero stuff a bit more
Zack Snyder could direct a really good Superman
does he know Superman do things I feel like
yeah there's a lot of it would destroy the world
no but I honestly I wonder what it would look
like to have Henry Cavill because he's done so
many other things outside of Superman like would
that movie Feel Like a Rock movie or would it feel
like the Man of Steel flavor or would it feel like
you know going forward to the DC Universe because
this is a brand new start effectively like we're
changing what DC films is is the the inevitable
you know the two of them is that gonna Feel Like
a Man of Steel too what if Shazam 3 and Man of
Steel 2 the black Adam's Villain at both the Rocks
really controlling the DC Universe he's the Thanos
but he's like a full-time yeah I'm the big villain
and I'm the big hero everywhere on Black Adam
everyone's always said Black Adam should dominate
the DC Universe this is the hierarchy shift I
demanded the Black Adam everywhere but no I think
it's really interesting that we're getting more of
the Old Guard kind of when they announced Man of
Steel 2 103 in basically the same conversation I
wonder how much of this is because of what the
Rock did with Henry Cavill was it a domino you
know I think it just I think what happened here
is he helped show that you know maybe we didn't
need to do a whole reboot or a whole reset on the
DC Universe we just needed to kind of refine a
couple of things without being like a race at all
just start it all over again freaking out man it's
been a while since everyone's made the world with
this nervous I have that's actually Walter Hamada
wrote that he's like I don't know how to reboot
everything I think what happened with The Rock
was he kept hearing how much people like me
because we talked about it we're so overjoyed
and so overpowered I think he just got proud papa
bear energy like when I see him like leak it he's
always just like like I think he just got excited
so I don't know if he ever meant to but he's such
a good businessman he's such a good marketer
there has to be a part of his brain that's like
this thing that worked for me is going to work for
others I'm really proud of it okay I'm gonna tell
you well the original post-credits scene if I'm
not mistaken was Superman was gonna show up but
they were gonna kind of do a Shazam thing where
you don't really see his face and how that kind
of carried over into Peacemaker where there was
a superman but you don't see his face which is
so weird well they wanted to leave it open and
then Hollywood report order did I don't know if
you guys heard about it but there was reports came
out about Walter Hamada well you know everyone's
favorite band Walter Ramada not wanting Henry
Cavill specifically to be in there but Dwayne
Johnson sort of went around him went to uh the
producers Deluca and Abdi to give it the thumbs
up and they only shot this in September this is
post Comic-Con this was shot right before Labor
Day according to this article that was just now
that's nuts and that explains so much because
remember there was a bit of a kind of a vitriolic
response in parts of the crowd with Comic-Con when
Dwayne Johnson came out there and everyone was
hyping up that Henry Cavill is going to return
he's going to return physically there I believed
it I believed it and the way Dwayne Johnson was
sort of dancing around it I've had my criticisms
of of the movie and I've had my uh opinions about
what the conversation was sort of morphing like
when it came to Dwayne Johnson assuming like he
has like this unusual control over the DC films or
at least the ones he's involved with right however
knowing that this came out in September knowing
the way he reacts to fans knowing the way he
listens knowing that man people really want Henry
Cavill Superman I gotta make sure this happens
because this is the one like this would not have
happened if it weren't for him and I think that is
so insanely awesome that it was him listening to
the fans like I'm not a big fan of this movie but
damn do I respect the fact that he went all out
like that to get Henry Cavill especially being
in the crowd and you know they have videos in a
Comic Con with some people booing when it came
talking about Superman he would dance around the
subject of it of like because you know it hits you
Superman that conversation was already deep in
play and he was trying to get it done yeah he's
trying to get done this in September that means
when he's sitting there in July he's going like
I'm trying like it is yeah and I really respect
the fact that even after the movie comes out he's
still so wanting to know what that experience was
for us us I think there's a reason the rock is
this big of a staple of of the movie entertainment
world and the reason he has so much control is I
don't think there's as many people as plugged in
and again this sounds like a Shameless name drop
but when I walked in the room to do the interview
he had seen our reactions and knew who I was no
one at his level was 6.7 million followers or
whatever on Instagram does their own Instagram
except the rock like The Rock was the one that
like picked the screenshot and sent it out
because he knew this channel that means he's that
plugged into the fans he's that invested in what
people wanted I need to reshoot might not spoiler
review dude Johnson's gonna watch her wrestle
well it's only cropping and koi into his montages
and Sean and Greg aren't included in those
Instagram videos some people were [__] talking
about the non-spoiler review gotta be honest and
then Greg's like make sure koi doesn't do a review
because he liked it keep that positivity off the
real rejects there's not other actors of his
level and producers of his level that are that
Hands-On because he made this happen because he
knew that's what people wanted I mean this changes
the DC Universe like he single-handedly did change
the hierarchy power moves like this is something
beautiful because knowing the journey and the
build up how it was like this forsaken Superman
this is so weird they're gonna do faceless Castle
again I know it's just like the Superman and Henry
Cavill was in purgatory when I'm like this is kind
of strange how we're not doing anything with it
and it took Dwayne Johnson fighting that's what's
so weird is Henry cavill's such a good Superman
he clearly loves the character the fans want it
those are the three ingredients you need yes you
want the actor to be invested you want the fans
to want it and you want it to be the right casting
Choice which it clearly was it's very strange that
it took a another movie 14 years after his movie
or whatever it was to be like no no he's back like
that's a weird that's unfortunate bizarre what's
ever happened in the history of any medium well
yeah I thought it was a beautiful post-credits
scene The Rock has been you know kind of a little
bit unclear of where he thinks the direction
should go after this it's like obviously he wants
a Black Adam versus Superman movie like obviously
he wants that to happen is that the next movie we
don't know we have no idea Shazam should probably
interact with like Adam at some point yeah I mean
it's like do you hop immediately to Black Adam
versus uh Superman or do you do one in between
this Black Adam versus Shazam I would do Shazam
3 with Black Adam as the villain that'd be cool
like I would call it Shazam 3 had blackout in the
villain that way you get one more movie to fall
in love with this take on Black Adam because you
know a lot of times when you got that big conflict
movie you want to be established in the character
so you make Black Adam the antagonist that'll
further you know solidify him as the anti-hero
then you do a Superman versus a Black Adam movie
yeah all right guys what are your thoughts leave
them down below follow koi on Tick Tock subscribe
click that Bell leave a like catch you all soon